About ten years ago, I
left all people behind
and went into the
wilderness alone.
I've learned that change
is always happening
but I've learned to be more
at peace with that
because that's how nature works.
I've learned that change
doesn't happen by pushing
but by making room.
I've learned to step back
and see patterns
and to work with what's under
the surface of things.
And all of the time, all of the time,
I'm learning to care more.
We're the first generations,
perhaps with the responsibility
to define leadership on behalf
of our whole planet.
We're the first generations,
perhaps on the edge
of seeing the destruction
of our whole world.
So what is leadership now?
Well, I think it's a choice.
It's a choice to come back
and challenge
everything and redefine it
using the rules of nature.